chester bennington 'he's wife breaks her
silence after his death a week after the
Lincoln Park singer was found dead of a
suicide by hanging his wife - Linda
Bennington is speaking out in a
statement to ET the 40 year old model
who married Chester in 2006 and is the
mother of their son Tyler and twin
daughters Lili and Lila said quote we
had a fairytale life and now it has
turned into some sick Shakespearean
tragedy how do I move on how do I pick
up my shattered soul adding the only
answer I know is to raise our babies
with every ounce of love I have I want
to let my community and the fans
worldwide know that we feel your love
may God bless us all and help us turn to
one another when we are in pain Chester
would have wanted us to do so rest in
peace my love the late singer was found
dead at his home in California the
morning of July 20th Linkin Park was
touring for their seventh studio album
when he died the remainder of the tour
has been cancelled in the wake of his
death